[music]
as long as i can remember
i've always been a romantic i was
dating the girl of my dreams
the moment i took my cover
a broken heart and
worked it up with a mate made it up with a mate
welcome to the whole sorry
guess i'm really making me  worry
you're spat i've been here for a whole day
that's just not healthy i'll
get my us drops overview get over
them by sitting around with
dragging to my parents' brand new beach house
go and let you grow up
i know where they say that you  half
the time a relationship postage completely
over that [ __ ] they say that
based on the formula 1 to 12 1 half
already a bang and forget everything
you can because adolescents i do
n't know if that works like that
more unimaginative and has a
lot of citations  officially started
we're here because your almost
always loitering around in a vagina
maybe that's always there  n goes
and she pulls out
every time you use the word love in
relation to a woman real
i'm spencer
i don't remember telling her
that was so bizarre she just wanted
what i'm so sorry you have to go
through there
you're looking  no girlfriend mean you
're looking for a good time
it's all just show man
[music]
holy [ __ ] i created a monster
that's right get what you wanted
right party stud i'm not a party
stud then let's start over or
there's something special about katy  i
think it might click you know
no no repeat
[music]
oh my god it's not that i'm
actually a hopeless romantic
really what have you done to me i'm
pretty much done even listened to
did you listen to what were you
thinking what  if you go the world get
it
[music]
i'll be us later
party guy i'm not a party guy i'm not a party
guy